[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and after a one-week
break the my hero academia manga is back
with chapter 159 I want to thank all of
you who commented on my review of the
previous boku no hero chapter that you
want me to keep doing this so let's get
right into the new chapter of course if
you enjoyed these videos leave a like to
let me know and don't forget to
subscribe and click that notification
bell if you want to be notified whenever
a new review is uploaded this chapter is
called the end and the epic battle
between overhaul and Dec who does in
fact end but then all of that is thrown
out the window crazy plot twist at the
very end of the chapter and of course
spoilers ahead at the beginning of the
chapter we see chrono stasis who simply
can't believe that chi or overhaul would
ever lose however he decided that in
case overhaul does lose he has to get
the product and the serum and escape he
prepares to kill eyes away before
escaping but thankfully the police and
sun-eater show up in time to stop him
and he is taken into custody along with
the other members of the a preset back
on the battlefield overhaul is giving it
his absolute all but with the help of
Ares incredible quark Deku is able to
finally defeat him however because he
kept using such a huge amount of power
against overhaul Deku is suddenly
overcome by immense pain and Aizawa
looks at Deku - apparently cancel out
one for all so that Deku would stop
feeling so much pain at least that's
what I think happened here I'm not sure
if he was also looking at arrey and
deactivating her quirk but at the end of
the day the aftermath of the battle is
gruesome with many people injured
however Deku seems fine but arey is
unconscious and feverish so she is
rushed to the hospital in an ambulance
we then see Sir Knight AI who we know is
badly injured but still alive and
kicking he calls out to Deku and tells
him that dec who really did succeed in
twisting the future and creating a
different outcome than the one sir
Knight I had foreseen Deku tossin
but he has to pull through because he
needs to see all mite again but then sir
night eye is presumably taken away to
receive treatment
now if Deku could change his fate then
perhaps all mite will be able to do so
as well this is definitely an
interesting development guys and despite
the heavy toll and many injuries the
rescue is complete and deku strong
desire to finally rescue Eddy has become
a reality everything seems fine as the
members of the eighth precepts of death
are being transported to a special
hospital for villains 11 members in
total along with the bullets and a
capsule that had not been previously
reported but as they are travelling in
the police vehicle they are cut off by a
truck and in that truck we see shigaraki
mr. compress and Dobby and they are
preparing to put their own plan into
motion so just when we thought that this
long intense arc had finally ended after
an epic and rewarding battle everything
changes in an instant as shigaraki
prepares to presumably capture all of
the members of the 8 precepts along with
their bullets and the mysterious capsule
now this capsule I am betting contains
the serum that chrono stasis had
mentioned earlier and of course in the
previous chapter we learned that
overhaul had planned to create a serum
that would restore the quirks of those
who lost them so that he could sell this
serum at a high price this is a huge
deal of course because this confirms
that our boy media will indeed be able
to regain his quirk one day the only
problem is that the serum will now
likely be in the hands of shigaraki and
the league of villains
now I just want to talk about shigaraki
for a second here we knew that once
token twice betrayed the 8 precepts that
he was up to something but I did not see
this coming instead of the legal
villains falling under the control of
the eighth precepts as overhaul had
wanted shigaraki looks like he is about
to take control of the members of the
eight presets
along with their quirky racing bullets
and the serum which is a huge
development it really makes you think
how far she got aki has developed from a
villain prone to
tantrums and incapable of making
long-term plans - a double-crossing
master planner who stayed one step ahead
of the eight precepts he is now
comparing his strategy to shogi and
clearly planning things out very careful
and this speaks to the fact that while
Deku has been advancing throughout the
series as the main protagonist
shigaraki has also been advancing as the
antagonist and eventually these two are
sure to become epic arch rivals with
Deku having one for all on his side and
shigaraki having all for one support
assuming that all four one escapes
captivity but I think this is entirely
possible in the future and that's it a
short quick chapter but a lot of things
happened all at once
really really epic let me know what you
guys thought of the chapter and the
conclusion to the epic battle between
overhaul and Deku also be sure to let me
know down in the comments what you think
about the serum and the importance of
this in the future and of course about
shigaraki and his development
what is the league of villains planning
what is gonna be their next move let me
know down below if you enjoyed these
reviews be sure to leave a like to let
me know and don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
can be notified every time I upload a
new review as always thank you so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]